good morning good afternoon everyone my
name is jim park and i'm one of the
senior scientists from military sigma
today i would like to present our zlatic
onyx ii microfluidics platform
which offer precise on-demand control
over various cellular micro environments
enabling dynamic life cell imaging
here's our line of our presentation
today i'll briefly cover the basics of
dynamic live cell imaging
as well as the challenges associated
with setting up such capabilities
i will then give a brief intro to our
zlasic platform
which offer turn key based solutions to
enable dynamic live cell imaging
with any existing inverted microscopes
then part of the presentation today will
be applications demonstrating the
utility of cell lasik
uh with particular emphasis given to
suspension cells
such as t lymphocytes which play a
crucial role
in immuno oncology
let's start with some basic background
information
uh on dynamic lines of imaging
i think by now it is very well
established that lifestyle imaging
offered tremendous biological insight
over more traditional static imaging
release
spatial and temporal information
for example let's take a look at the
static image in the middle of this slide
what you see in the middle of the slide
is a bunch of tv input signs which are
loaded with a green
costume indicator fluorescent dye to
simply put
uh not much insight can be gained from
such a static image
perhaps other than what appears to be
different level
of dioptake as seen by different
fluorescent intensities
among the t cells however
if we are to take a time-lapse image of
these t-cells
showing the bottom of the spine we start
to gain deeper
understanding and awareness to the
spatiotemporal dynamics of the cells at
single cell level
in this particular experiment t cells
were kept at resting state
and then activated with ionomythin
because increasing
intracellular calcium very important
step in t-cell activation
already a couple observations can be
made which were not possible
when we're just looking at the static
image in the middle
of the slide for example we start to
notice that
the t cells are affiliating in their
calcium level
during resting states so they're going
back and forth they're getting brighter
and dimmer
and also that there's a significant
level of heterogeneity
among the t cells in terms of their
calcium responses
let's play the movie cell to better
appreciate
what is going on
in summary dynamic live cell imaging
offer analysis
of cellular events at single cell level
that's enabling study of population
heterogeneity
study of cellular biology as a function
of microenvironmental perturbations
as we have seen in the previous movie
here for example we can study the
calcium responses of t
cells before during and after their
activation
while will control when and how t-cell
agonies
in this case introduction of iodomycin
is control other common example would be
dynamic gas control
to create normoxic and hypoxic condition
and we'll go over that in greater detail
later on
last but not least is the atomization
where we now can study various cellular
responses
such as morphology velocity signaling
as well as a cell cell interaction as a
function of time
to really obtain spatiotemporal
information of
any given biological system
so it sounds great when we talk about
live cell imaging but then uh let's take
a step back and think about
some of the challenges uh in terms of
building or actually buying a system
which will enable dynamic lifestyle
imaging
this is an image from wikipedia and
nicely demonstrates
a complexity associated with such a
system
these are very large and complex systems
with high price tag
requiring well-trained scientists to
operate
also in all cases additional
do-it-yourself components are required
to establish perfusion and through the
capability
in order to create true dynamic imaging
system
these components such as pumps and
perfusion chambers
with associated controllers will further
create complexity
and increase associated prices now i do
want to point
out that there are simplified versions
of such a system that do exist
however they're very expensive still
most of them are still well over 70k
and also our simpler systems tend to
have a close system tend to be a closed
system
with limited functionality and
capability
switching gears then let's talk about
our zlat platform
it is a true turnkey product
with the integrated microenvironmental
control system
coupled to a microfluidic plate where
cells can be cultured
uh and imaged on demand a controller the
black box in the middle
is size of the typical 13-inch laptop in
x and y dimension
uh and if you have to stack up four of
these laptops
it'll become equal in height as well it
is extremely
portable and it was built with a
mobility in mind
our platform offers software driver and
on-demand control of temperature
gas and fluidics of the plate and thus
making dynamic lifestyle imaging
experiments possible
the software is extremely intuitive and
enables step-by-step protocol building
where each step can be built would user
define
time temperature gas and proficient
parameters
such as flow rate
the planet's standard 96 well format
footprint
and the image in the center shows one of
our plate
preloaded with colored dyes to show
individual layout
of the fluidics in essence it is a
system
of interconnected microfluidic channels
with micro tissue culture chamber in the
middle
as you can see in this cartoon for each
row
indicated as a group 1 2 3 and 4
all the individual well within the group
are connected
to micro tissue culture chamber via
individual microfluidic
channels which are basically the colored
lines
for visualization this enables up to
four
independent experiments to be conducted
per plane
when connected to the controller unit
via manifold
now media or reagent in each one of
these inlet wells
can be pressed down via positive
pressure this will then move the media
or reagent from that well
into the micro tissue culture chamber
essentially
this creates a system where any desired
media
or region can be precisely delivered
to the cells in the chamber at desired
time
for specific duration and with specific
flow rate
since the plate can be temperature and
gas control
we can now control cellular micro
environment in dynamic
on-demand fashion the bottom of the
plate is also made of
n1.5 glass for clear imaging and you'll
see the quality of our our images in the
later slide
including the confocal applications
last thing i would like to mention is
that since these are microfluidics
played
we can also introduce specific micro
dimensional features that are aimed at
certain applications such as
imaging of suspension cells or
maintenance of chemotactic
gradient
let's talk about applications now
let's start with the hypoxia application
our system has two
inlets to enable gas switching for
example we can connect two tanks with
percent oxygen and zero percent oxygen
and switch back and forth between two
gas
inputs graft in the middle shows change
in oxygen level
within the micro tissue chamber as we
cycle gas conditions from lamoxic
to hypoxic we have introduced reverse
fluorescent oxygen sensor itdp
whose fluorescence is inversely related
to oxygen level
into our micro tissue chamber for
fluorescent imaging
y-axis shows the fluorescent level of
rtdp
x-axis shows the time of experiment
we are indirectly measuring oxygen level
with a micro tissue chamber within the
mycolitis chamber
as we change oxygen levels
and we are also looking at media with
and without feasible bias here
as well as the different flow rates as
indicated on the legend
as you can see under the maxi condition
fluorescence
wooden micro tissue chamber is very low
as we switch to hypoxic condition
fluorescence
starts to increase and within two hours
it reaches
equilibrium we can cycle this process
so if we switch back to the market
condition fluorescence will start to
decrease
and again reach equilibrium within two
hours
we can even maintain prolonged high
perfect conditions
for 48 hours or even longer
graph on the right shows expression
level of headphone alpha
t regulator of hypoxic response of the
various oxygen level
y-axis shows fluorescence of the reverse
oxygen sensor rtbt
as well as the heatphone alpha and
nuclear damping staining
x-axis again a timely experiment
as we switch from normoxic to hypoxic
condition
from t equals zero to t equals 180
minutes
we see increase in rtdp fluorescence
followed by increase in f1 alpha
expression
whereas the dpdp fluorescence is uh
sorry whereas the other dappy
fluorescence
is unchanged notice how the heatphone
alpha expression which is the biological
response
legs thereby environmental oxygen change
as shown by
change in fluorescence of btbp
if we switch back from hypoxic condition
as shown from t equals 180
to the rest of the experiment we see
oxygen level going up
and the expression of his alpha
disappearing with no
change in bathy fluorescence
now let's look at intracellular oxygen
level and how they're affected
by hypoxia here we're going to use
intracellular hypoxic probe
a biotracker 520 this probe is highly
cell permeable
and becomes fluorescent only inside of
cell
under hypoxic condition images shows
a431 cells loaded with and without the
probe
and subjected to hypoxic conditions for
16 hours
using salinity setup that i just
mentioned to you in previous slides
image on the bottom left shows the cells
becoming
bright green due to the activation of
the intracellular hypoxia
probe now i will show you the livestream
movie
generated on the larmoxy versus hypoxic
condition
using cell laser
another common life cell imaging
application is to study intracellular
trafficking
and morphologies of intracellular
organelles here we're going to study
autophagy response by visualizing
autophagons
formation under formed under hypoxia
conditions
cells in this study expressed gfc to use
lc3 protein which
localized to liposomal compartment
under normoxic condition cells exceeded
broad
green fluorescence under hypoxic
conditions
cellular stress activates apophy
and then of the phagosomes formation can
be seen
as a distinctive intracellular pump tape
formation
using the cellulitic setup described
before we can cycle
back and forth between mammoxy hypoxic
and then normalcy condition to study
spatial
temporal dynamics of autophagy responses
let's take a closer look by viewing live
cell movies
are generated using celes
obviously there's a lot more information
one can gain from understanding spatial
temporal dynamics
of protein trafficking this slide
summarizes the receptor internalization
processes
using a549 cell expressing gfpc use the
egf receptor
all culturing and experimental
conditions were done
using the lasik although the upper left
image
shows the broad membrane distribution of
gfp
egf receptor when cells are cultured in
one of our planes the image in the
middle
shows initial change in the distribution
of the receptors when
its ligand egf is introduced to the cell
the receptor starts to close along the
membrane surfaces
followed by eventual receptor
internalization
and trafficking to liposomal compartment
where it produces that distinctive
puncture formation
as shown in the right side of the image
again let's take a closer look with the
livestream movie
of these processes
i've mentioned that one of the advantage
of microfluid plates
is the ability to fabricate small
dimensional features
aimed at specific applications here's
one example
where we are enabling directional
migration of cells
while maintaining chemotactic gradient
through small dimensional features
figure on the upper panel shows the
layout of the micro tissue chamber
surrounded by two
flow channels the flow channels and
micro tissue chamber
are separated by micro poles barrier
which enables creation of chemotactic
gradient
when two channels are perfused
simultaneously
the images on the upper right shows one
channel
bottom part of the image flowing with
50 solution and the other channel upper
part of the image
flowing with blank buffer as you can see
over time
there is a 50 concentration gradient
going from bottom to the top image of
the bottom
shows a chemotherapy responses of
ht1080 cells using this setup
upper channel has chemoattractant
flowing through it
bottom channel has corresponding blank
buffer blowing through it
over time there is a directional
migration
of cells towards the chemotactic
gradient
once again let's take a closer look
another advantage of microdimensional
feature
is to enable live cell imaging of
suspension cells a very pertinent
feature
uh for something like study of immuno
oncology where suspension cells like t
cell play a key role unlike adherent
cells
suspension cells pose a unique
challenges
during lifestyle imaging due to their
drifting
and defocusing images on upper left
explains the design principle for our
trap plates here we have introduced
vertical
pillars with a ceiling height of 12
microns
which effectively trap suspension cells
in a single focal plane
and prevent drifting and defocusing
as you can see on the bottom left with
the image
labeled regular slide substantial cells
are very difficult to focus uh in
general because they're
non-adherent if you look at the same
cell
captured under our trap play you can see
all cells are in monolayer
under single focal plane enabling
quality imaging
with ability to track single individual
cells
next slide movie uh cell movie will
highlight
these features
we can take advantage of these trap
features uh
and using dexgate immune synapse
formation
during t cell interaction with antigen
presenting b cells
as an example immune synapse formation
is
not only important for t cells and
antigen presenting cells
such as being cells or molecules but
also it's a critical
during the lytic cellular event between
t cells
and the tumor cells for immunocollege
applications
uh images shown here are snapshots taken
from lifestyle movie
using track features to capture an image
suspension t-cell
interacting with antigen-presenting
b-cells
notice how all the cells are in focus
and there are no challenges to track
individual cells and study their
movement
and morphology at a single cell level
let's play the actual movie
another example application of track
plates
uh is to check suspension cell aptosis
uh
in real time here we are perfusing t
cells with a nucleus caspase-3
active autopsies probe and nx in five
upon activation of the death receptor of
cd95
t-cells will undergo programmed cell
death
images from the bottom are snapshots
taken from lifestyle movie where t-cells
are undergoing program cell death
upon cd95 activation first we can
visualize
nuclear condensation upon cathode
evacuation
as indicated by the green fluorescence
followed by phosphatidylserine
expression
on the membrane of the dying cell as
indicated by
red fluorescence let's take a look at
the lifestyle movie itself
i would like to close by just going over
two more live cell applications
uh one is the long-term culture
capability uh outside lasik
two images are shown of the neuronal
cells from
a 21 and four-day experiments
respectively
indicated cells were grown for the
specified duration on our plate
and then in situ immunostain with
specific indicated markers
to show that cells were maintaining
their intended phenotypes
of course during any time during the
culturing
the time lapse can be taken using these
plates
for the cell we have some movies coming
up for neural stem cell differentiation
so please stay tuned
another application is growing cells in
3d matrix
on the left side we show 3d mcf tencel
growing in celesy plate versus
conventional
four chamber culture slide for
comparison
in both cases cells have formed a nice
theory this also indicate
that it's possible to purchase 3d matrix
that contains cells in order to create
cellular 3d structures
using our externalizing platform on the
left side is a snapshot
taken from livestream movies of growing
steroids
let's take a look at the lifestyle movie
the laser can also be used for non-live
cell imaging applications
as i briefly mentioned before after
lifestyle imaging
cells in the microchamber can now be in
situ stained
uh image in the middle shows the hela
cell uh they were stained after
lifestyle energy experiment
using the zelizig as an automated
staining platform
using the setups indicated on the left
side of the slide
in addition to instituting cells or
their lysate
can be extracted for further downstream
analysis
such as flow or for pcr and sequencing
applications
in closing
we offer different plates with different
dimensional features
in the different applications so please
reach out to us for any specific
uh your needs or your application would
be very happy to
have conversations with you
and we also enjoy growing a list of
publications in top journals
we have well over 700 publications now
and they're still growing rapidly and
some of the recent publications are
highlighted
on the right side
in summary cellular biology
is complex system with dynamically
changing micro environment
and cellular responses dynamic life cell
imaging is an
indispensable tool to better understand
this event
the lasik brings programmable dynamic
environmental control to address these
needs
to cell culture turnkey
ready to use microfluidics and mycocide
chambers or precise radiation of cell
culture conditions are possible
with cell laser system growing
suits of microfluidic plates enable
investigation of a wide
range of cellular responses and as i
mentioned before
if you have a specific questions from
your application
uh please we'll be very happy to have
discussions with you
with that i just would like to thank
everyone
as mentioned before my name is june if
you have any questions
please reach out to me at any time we
also have a
troubled information on our website
simply type in
australia.com in your browser that is
sell
with 2l followed by asic
once again thank you everyone for your
time today and look forward to hearing
that from you